[Music]
foreign
for Saturday evening's press preview
it's our first look at what is on the
front pages of tomorrow's papers and
tonight we'll see what's making the
headlines with Rachel shabby and also
Claire Ellicott but first of all let's
take a look at those from Pages for you
we're going to begin with the people
half of NHS docs in Mental Health crisis
is on their front page as it looks at
the developing situation for Frontline
medics
while the observer looks at political
responses to reports of an NHS crisis
with the headline cabinet split over NHS
pay piles pressure on sunac
and the front of the Sunday Telegraph
looks at Kirsten's stance on it all its
headline I will slash nonsense
bureaucracy in the NHS
Tori donor tycoons four and a half
million pounds to destroy PPE reads the
front of the Sunday Mirror they're
exclusive and the front of the Sunday
Mail also looks at the conservatives its
headline Tories two million pound
jackpot
sex assault during riot at Migrant
Center reads the front of the Sunday
Express
while the Sunday Times looks to the
Royals for their front page the headline
there Windsor peace Talk plan ahead of
the coronation I wonder and don't forget
that you can scan the QR code that you
see on screen join program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us discussing them and
tonight I'm joined by the journalist a
Rachel shabby and Claire helicopter
acting Deputy political editor of the
mail on Sunday great to see you this
Saturday evening thank you very much for
joining us let's get cracking shall we
uh Rachel why don't you kick things off
for us at front of the Sunday Telegraph
they have got an interview with sakir
starmer and he says he's going to slash
bureaucracy in the NHS
uh that's right an incredibly
disappointing interview I have to say
from the labor leader who says as you
point out the goal for a labor
government would be to slash what he
describes as mind-boggling NHS
bureaucracy he says the service must
quote reform or die and he says that we
need to move away from our quote
well-meaning reverence towards the NHS
um a a an attitude which he claims has
supplanted reality now this is
unfortunate because the reality
according to the people who work in the
NHS is not that we have some kind of
fantasy view of it or that it is overtly
bureaucrat bureaucratic but rather that
it has been underfunded systematically
underfunded through 12 years of
conservative rule kirst armor knows that
because kirst armor knows the last time
the labor labor party was in government
we didn't have these problems it was
receiving more funding uh as percentage
of GDP waiting lists were shorter uh
Staffing was higher at the moment
what people who actually work in the HS
are talking about is the underfunding is
the under investment is the lack of
Staffing and the fact that uh social
care is also on its knees due to
underfunding so that the hospitals the
NHS service is only really working to
two-thirds bed capacity because the
other third is taken up by people who
are fit to be discharged but can't
because social care packages are in
place so it's just nonsense and frankly
insulting for the labor leader to make
these claims about the NHS particularly
when people who are actually work in the
NHS are saying something very very
different uh interesting uh Claire what
what do you make of what Rachel had to
say there
well I think there are several really
interesting
um things about this piece being in the
Telegraph and um clearly securma is is
sort of parking his tanks on the Tory's
lawn because this is something Steve
Barkley was talking about just a few
weeks ago about slashing bureaucracy
it's a very standard sort of Tory
approach to these things how do you save
money you cut all the red tape that's
holding back these services and um the
fact that kirstan was saying it and
we've had him recently talking about
taking back control and you know just
saying a lot of sort of right Tory
things he's clearly in election mode
he's clearly looking to win over some of
those voters that haven't been voting
for labor that have defected to the
Tories in recent times now his his
message on the NHS in you know the Tory
Bible the telegraph will go down like a
couple of sick for many of the labor
voters who who really do treasure the
NHS but I can see how Kirsten would
think this was a key thing for him to do
in order to win back some of those
photos that the labor party lost in
2019. okay well let's stay with the the
NHS and the front of the Observer uh
Rachel there's been some breaking news
tonight the Royal College of Nursing
ramping up the pressure saying it's
going to announce fresh strikes for
February uh which could be uh uh uh uh
many more nurses going on strike than
we're going to see next week meanwhile
The Observer is reporting that there's a
a split over how to resolve the issue
with actually Steve Barkley coming out
more on the side of uh nurses but the
treasury are holding back
that's right um so the Observer is
reporting this sort of slight twist in
the story which is as you say health
secretary Steve Barkley privately saying
that
um there really should be more money uh
for nurses ambulance workers and other
essential workers within the NHS
um according to this story he is at odds
with both the treasury and the Prime
Minister
um both of whom want to hold out
essentially and face down these strikes
but what's interesting is that Steve
Barkley the health secretary is actually
asking the unions now to help him make
the case he wants them to lean in on the
idea that actually
more pay would avoid this huge drain of
Staff that's happening in the NHS at the
moment there's this big Exodus
um partly because people are burnt out
and stressed which we'll look at in a
minute but also partly because uh the
pay is so appalling and the training is
so appalling and so his big
um claim here or his big sort of
um uh his methodology here is that he
wants to lean on that premise to try and
get more money out of the treasury and
actually pay nurses and other NHS
workers more yeah I mean where's it all
going Claire I mean the start of the
week on on Monday there seemed to be
some movement between the two sides
didn't they that there seemed to be uh
positive noises coming out of of
discussions but um here we are at the
end of the week no further forward
yes exactly and further strikes
threatened as you point out and I think
the interesting thing about this
briefing is it's it's come from the
union so I'm not quite sure what Steve
Barkley's taking it is but
um there is this sort of interesting
idea that as as a Tory you you think
probably that you know you don't want to
spend loads more money and taxpayers
money on Services if they're not
necessarily getting better but once
you're in a department and um you're
being told that you need to find money
out of your existing budget to pay full
pay Rises for workers
um your perspective probably changes a
bit and um this story has suggested that
Steve Barkley the health secretary is
pitted against them Richie sunak and
Jeremy Hunt in the treasury and that
they're they're pressing back and they
don't want to make these huge
commitments um I wonder if it's a case
of good cop bad cop but like you say
things are dragging on and unions are
threatening further strikes so the
sooner there can be some sort of
solution to this the better yeah okay um
I've just realized that all our front
pages certainly in the first half of the
paper review are about the the Health
Service in some form or another the
front of the Sunday people half of NHS
doctors in Mental Health crisis it's a
very depressing headline Rachel uh
you've read further um online
that's right so it's incredibly
depressing but I suppose unsurprising
that people working inside the NHS are
suffering with their own health problems
and their own mental health problem
problems 52 suffer uh poor mental health
um and panic panic attacks are happening
amongst uh people who previously had no
no history of anxiety of course it's not
hard to see why uh the conditions that
NHS workers are working so hard in are
appalling short staffed for one but just
the stress of having to work in
conditions where you're constantly
unable essentially to do your job uh you
know imagine that these these industries
are care Industries and the absolute
stress of not being able to
um do what you need to do to help people
the fact that you're needing to treat
people and care for people people in
hospital corridors the fact that you're
an ambulance worker that's waiting hours
outside an a e because there's not
enough space to bring in uh the patient
that you're trying to look after or
potentially try to save their life
um so it's really no wonder uh that
these staff are essentially facing so
much stress and it's affecting their
mental health yeah
um absolutely right let's move on uh
just very briefly Claire to the Sunday
Mirror just tell us about this story
it's um regarding a Tory donor and PPE
contracts
yes so this is a quite a controversial
story um someone who's donated 730 000
pounds to the Tory party
um has he won a huge contract for
millions of pounds of PPE and is now
being paid to um essentially get rid of
all this PPE now this feeds into the
wider Scandal of of money being wasted
on all of these huge contracts um during
the pandemic and there's a lasting
Legacy there's millions and millions of
pounds worth of taxpayers money that was
spent on a lot of this PPE equipment at
the summer quite a lot of it wasn't
actually usable and but it was
commissioned in sort of the heat of the
pandemic when people were desperate that
ministers were desperate desperate to
get hold of Mars was a worldwide battle
to try to secure some of this stuff but
it's clear that real mistakes were made
and this is just the latest example
we've had Michelle moan the tour repair
and it's caught up in all sorts of
Scandal if you've stepped away from the
Lords as a result of it and um it's it's
just an ongoing in Saga and we'll sort
of probably never know quite how much
money was wasted
um in all securing all of these
contracts some of which were ultimately
useless yeah and their response on the
front page at least from that donut will
try and get to his side of it uh maybe
in the next hour thank you both for now
we're going to go to uh a break coming
up this story on the front of the times
it's headline wins a peace Talk plan
ahead of Coronation talk about that and
more after the break
[Music]
welcome back Rachel and Claire still
with us for the Press preview
um Claire front of Sunday Telegraph
um all the papers uh reporting on the
execution of alireza akbari what's
what's the telegraph's take
so um they're saying that the British
response response to this may be that um
they pull out of the nuclear deal that
is supposed to be going ahead and now
the the target with this is that this is
a he is a British Iranian dual National
he's executed a run of accused of being
an MI6 spy and um the British government
have sort of been taken by surprise by
this in some ways and um they don't
they've kind of had a reaction today
they have sanctioned the prosecutor
General in Iran they have
um they have summoned the Ambassador
from Iran and they've recalled our
ambassador to Tehran and to temporarily
to to speak to and the you know the
foreign secretary in Britain and um so
this is their reaction at the moment but
it's clear that that's not
quite big enough given what's actually
happened and so they're going to need to
go further with this there's a lot of
discussion about what they might do
whether they might pull out of the
nuclear deal this is something that's
been broken for a long time and could
have huge huge implications or whether
they prescribe the Revolutionary guards
who runs Iran as a terrorist group and
that's something that could happen but
it's not sounding that likely and
whatever happens they're going to have
to take a kind of more hard-line stance
on this and the foreign secretary
Beverly is due to go to um the us next
week and have you know speak to his
counterparts there so whether there's a
UK US sort of response to this as a
result
um and we will probably find out quite
soon yeah it's a difficult line isn't it
Rachel for Britain To Tread but but
quite frankly The Diplomatic moves made
today you know recalling the Ambassador
from Tehran temporarily sanctions on the
prosecutor General in Iran I mean
they're going to make no impact
well yeah it is a difficult line to
trade as you say and and the worry is of
course that you know this is this is a
horrendous horrendous act
um and the worry is of course that this
might be sending out a warning signal
um to protesters in Iran and perhaps
others in Iran saying look these are the
these are the things that we're prepared
to do so is absolutely chilling the
trouble is of course that um having some
impact or taking some ACT
um to wind back commitments to the Iran
deal is going to have
Global consequences it might be a bit
sort of cutting off your nose despite
your face in terms of its ramifications
um but I think there are definitely
Avenues to pursue in terms of how on
Earth is was did this even even happen
legally what are the legal consequences
uh can anyone be brought to Justice or
can in an international Court
um just for what what happened and it is
an absolutely appalling appalling act so
yes of course uh some that does need to
see some consequences okay let's move on
to uh let's move on to Harry and the
Royals shall we um something which I
think the Daily Mail may have covered a
little bit Claire um over the last
couple of weeks Sunday times has got
this story about a peace Talk plan
um having to take place before the
coronation I mean is that is that likely
given everything that Harry has said in
his book
well
um you would struggle if you're in the
royal family wouldn't you to um Envision
this but nevertheless there there are
said to be plans of foot and to try to
reunite the warring factions of Windsor
and the coronation takes place in May
there's not that much time to engineer a
Reconciliation given quite how seismic
some of the revelations in Harry's book
spare have been
um nevertheless they are you you know
Prince Charles's type King Charles now
has um signaled that he does want to
engineer some sort of you know
reconciliation with his son and um
there's a big question now as to as to
whether Prince Harry and Megan will be
invited and um what exactly happens and
the implications of that and I'd imagine
if you are a royal courtier at the
moment that is um taking up an awful lot
of your time and nevertheless that you
know that there has to be some sort of
reproachment because this it's just rock
the nation hasn't it and um and it's
huge and
um I think you know everyone would
probably like to see something positive
happen with this family yeah quick
thought Rachel
I mean I think it's just about the king
not wanting to have his coronation sort
of put off track by more and more
stories coming from from Harry who who
shows no intention of stopping and I I
guess even people are on team Harry and
Megan are kind of thinking all right
this is getting a little bit too much
now you know just too much information
um and perhaps the Royal Family's
approach of oh if we say nothing it will
go away perhaps they've realized that
actually Harry's just going to keep
talking unless some move towards
reconciliation she says he's got another
book in him doesn't he or certainly he
he kept a lot of information out okay
thank you